bonjour jean maxime est bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors le monde des affaires on
en parle beaucoup moins on parle
beaucoup de la colère au niveau
diplomatique notamment de la france qui
se sent humiliée par la sphère des sous
marins australiens la rupture de ce
contrat gigantesque de sous marins signé
avec la france n'a pas permis n'a pas
mis le monde des affaires réellement aux
colères qui voilà la réalité sous un
autre angle absolument pas seulement des
affaires considèrent que la réalité elle
est beaucoup plus politique et cette
affaire marque inéluctablement que la
classe politique ne veut pas voir un
changement de rapport de force si vous
interrogez les avocats qui sont des
avocats internationaux et qui ont
l'habitude finalement de tous ses
contrats et bien cette affaire pour eux
a au moins le mérite de remettre les
pendules à l'heure vous savez c'est
raphaël rappelle aux responsables
politiques une réalité très crue du
poids politique de la france dans la
géopolitique d'aujourd'hui la france est
un tout petit pays dans un monde dominé
par deux superpuissances qui se
disputent une hégémonie internationales
ont fait semblant de le redécouvrir
aujourd'hui mais c'est ça la réalité les
états unis à l'ouest la chine à l'est
entre ces deux poids lourds impossible
d'exister la chine cherche à tout prix à
étendre son influence dans la zone indo
pacifique et cela depuis une dizaine
d'années depuis l'officialisation des
nouvelles routes de la soie avec en plus
la volonté à peine dissimulée de
s'approprier hong kong on voit bien ce
qui s'est passé à hong kong puis demain
peut-être formose ou même singapour
l'australie a donc décidé de se réarmer
et du même où elle a négocié un
rapprochement avec les américains et
avec les anglais lesquels cherchent
aussi avec boris johnson depuis le rexy
de nouveaux alliés hors jeu de sol
l'occasion est trop belle de réaffirmer
sa stratégie d'indépendance d'hégémonie
planétaire tout ça pour faire un petit
peu un pied-de-nez à l'europe quant aux
américains leur intérêt pour se protéger
des chinois était de plus en plus
évidente depuis de longues années il
fallait renforcer leur potentiel
militaire dans cette région d'où la
décision de signer sept nouvelles
alliances dans la perspective d'un
affrontement qui paraît inéluctable avec
la chine alors pour l'instant cet
affrontement c'est sur le terrain mic et
qu'en sera t il de l'avenir eh bien ça
on le verra je remarque c'est quoi
justement cette nouvelle alliance c'est
quoi précisément le locus locus alors
c'est un mot nouveau qui est apparu dans
notre vocabulaire c'est le nouveau nom
de cette nouvelle alliance alors dans
hocus vous avez au comme australie vous
avez royaume uni et puis vous avez les
états unis cette alliance doit soutenir
les intérêts des trois alliés en
renforçant le potentiel de sécurité de
défense d'où l'idée de construire
ensemble une industrie de la défense
plus intégrée avec des porcs ne aménagé
en australie notamment et des industries
d'armement plus sophistiqués et plus
lourds pour faire face à cette offensive
chee hwa qui paraît redémarrer ou
démarrer dans le pacifique alors est
évident que les alliés traditionnels de
l'amérique et de la grande bretagne
qu'ils n'étaient pas au courant peuvent
être logiquement vexé et franchement ils
ont raison d'être vexé parce qu'ils
auraient pu être mis au courant
cette alliance a été préparée quand même
depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois et pourquoi la france se
sont elles plus oublier que les autres
parce que la france était partie
prenante dans l'accord précédent et
parce que la france se retrouve éjecté
finalement de la scène pacifique la
france se rend compte qu'elle est un
petit pays je le répète l'europe qui
aurait pu réagir immédiatement a quand
même attendu trois jours avant de se
rassembler derrière la france pour
déplorer ce camouflet et se regrouper
derrière la france qui n'est toujours
pas fait on aurait pu être plus rapide à
bruxelles emmanuel macron a dû rappeler
ces ambassadeurs mais c'est un peu de
l'agitation alors bien sûr c'est grave
c'est sévère sites historiques mais ça
changera pas grand chose joe baydan
nicéphore du d'un mode excuses en
murmurant que la france restait un de
ses fidèles alliés et je m'adonne à
d'ailleurs dit qu'il allait réouvrir ses
frontières en faisant sauter le
passeport sanitaires là non plus ça ne
change pas grand chose c'est que dans la
logique des choses mais le président
américain ne semble pas pressé de
trouver une alternative et pour cause
cette situation qui provoque un
sentiment de trahison pourrait entraîner
une recomposition politique et entraîne
déjà une recomposition politique mais ce
ne sera pas davantage de la france alors
jean bart qu'en sera-t-il des effets
économiques a écouté a priori ce marché
de 11 sous marin représentait plus de 34
ou 35 milliards d'euros au total
alors c'est important c'est historique
bien mais les retombées sur l'industrie
française représentait moins de huit
milliards d'euros donc il faut quand
même marginalisée les choses alors ce ne
sont pas des pertes d'ailleurs en plus
ce sont des manques à gagner les régions
de cherbourg de brest soyons concrets
qui ont des bases navales spécialisé
dans les sous-marins vont perdre entre 7
et 8 milliards d'activité à l'échelle
des régions c'est sévère mais à
l'échelle du pays ça restera marginale
l'alternative serait de trouver de
nouveaux marchés de nouvelles
technologies les entreprises sont pas
paniqués dans cette affaire il peut y
avoir un petit problème d'image de la
france mais la france a les moyens je
parle de la france économique financière
et technologique de se redresser au
niveau européen ça pourrait être
l'occasion de renforcer son indépendance
et la force de la défense européenne
mais les pays européens en ont-ils
l'ambition politique peut un peu
probable on voit pas ça à moins qu
emmanuel macron fasse des miracles quand
il sera président des 27 vous savez qui
sera président de l'union européenne à
partir du mois de janvier la seule
consolation restera aujourd'hui le
cynisme des avocats internationaux qui
savent eux-mêmes que les ruptures de
contrat sont fréquentes elle entraîne
toujours des dédommagements alors un
contrat historique indemnités historique
des avocats très chères sont déjà au
travail cronje opération c'est vrai cela
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
s'était l'édito diplo et cause de la
matinale